let me ask you this because you
obviously have a serious amount of
jewelry
um
you know the the rabbit pendant is
insane but I do feel like you know when
you see something like you know you told
me that the pnb rock [ __ ] kind of hit
you man like we've just been seeing a
lot of artists lose their life over
jewelry and [ __ ] like are you a lot more
you know hesitant to move around with
all your [ __ ] on are you a lot more
alert you're always alert you know but
in terms of just like
you know I mean listen you live in L.A
there's a time and a place for all of
that stuff I think you know I mean um I
don't think you know
you don't gotta wear all your [ __ ] I
think any [ __ ] that wear all his [ __ ]
when you go outside is kind of like damn
you ain't damn okay let's see what I'm
saying like so I just feel like um
I feel like you should be able to do
what you want man and nobody should
[ __ ] touch you dog like but I don't
think that's reality I know it's not
reality I'm just saying you know I mean
like oh and I like a lot of people are
like everybody's a a a analyst when it
comes to these type of situations like
he shouldn't have did this he shouldn't
have did that he wouldn't bothering
nobody man I agree he wasn't bothering
nobody I don't give a [ __ ] where he was
at nobody should have [ __ ] with him I
agree and that's the problem with y'all
[ __ ] you know I'm saying like [ __ ]
think oh like [ __ ] I should be able to
do whatever the [ __ ] I want to wear I
know that ain't reality I know it's not
so I just protect what I got you know I
mean and it is what it is you know what
I'm saying like but you look at this
[ __ ] though
like you asked me about
um oh did I uh think about all like you
know what [ __ ] were saying and
all of this [ __ ] during during my
situation so you look at my situation
like [ __ ] like 30 [ __ ] came to
a restaurant I was eating it and I what
if I would have died yeah
oh man he was great he was that what
academics be saying I was a great rapper
on his post
but now since you know I'm saying since
[ __ ] tried to jump me oh man he got
jumped it's a different thing now what
if pnb rock you know what I'm saying
what you know
yeah
exactly exactly even worse and even
worse what if he would have just gave it
up
gave it up people been like yeah what if
you would have gave it up and lived it's
a lose lose for a [ __ ] so what the [ __ ]
y'all [ __ ] want from us yeah
that's real I would have gave it up
y'all y'all would have clowned me my
career y'all oh [ __ ] this [ __ ] ass
[ __ ] mm-hmm
but if I fight for mine and die
oh man you shouldn't even been there man
suck my dick all these fans all these
people I don't give a [ __ ] about none of
that dog at the end of the day yeah you
know what I mean like bro I should be
able to do what the [ __ ] I want to do
[ __ ] y'all
[ __ ] I work hard for mine
you know what I'm saying and hey
try it it is what it is man you know you
just gotta just pray every day and just
move correctly dog but that man
shouldn't he shouldn't have been
bothered he wasn't bothering nobody dog
you know what I'm saying he was having a
[ __ ] meal but it's good at the end of
the [ __ ] day dog yeah having a meal
with his girl
um
then the reason that [ __ ] touched me
like that because that could have been
me then whatever [ __ ] would have said
yeah
that shit's crazy then what
I just think we're just like
by growing up like I feel like when
Tupac and Biggie died it was such a big
deal because we weren't used to to
losing people but I feel like nowadays
it's like it happened so often that it's
like [ __ ] like
when like like rapping might be the most
dangerous job when people say that like
per capita [ __ ] is really
losing their life at a high level it
could be man that's why you got to use
this [ __ ] as a springboard to get you
somewhere else man yeah you know what
I'm saying because like [ __ ] just being
identified as a rapper like if a bunch
of [ __ ] here who he's a rapper he rap
he do what oh [ __ ] that already
automatically put eyes on you
[ __ ] see what they they want to
test your nuts they want to see if you
could protect what you got they want to
see if you could fight they want to see
if you about that [ __ ] you rhyming hmm
you know what I mean so you
automatically you know the [ __ ]
microscope from [ __ ] from other
[ __ ] uh punk ass rappers from
[ __ ] police you know what I mean so
you know it's you know it's it's a
difficult it's definitely a difficult
occupation to be and uh